in Australia's southeast weary
firefighters work swiftly to protect
communities this bushfire season has
already decimated more than 10 million
hectares of land in the southwest of New
South Wales this couple fears their
house could be next
Judith and Klaus Elba have lived here
for 20 years
they faced bush fires before but say
this season is different scared of
what's to come they've put food a
generator and their treasured
possessions in a bunker where they plan
to stay if fire reaches the property and
I've never really seen it this bad so I
think it's not usually like this
Australia's usually in a lovely place
authorities are assessing conditions
constantly warning that fire could
return to some already affected areas or
start in new spots this bushfire season
has already destroyed thousands of
houses it's already Australia's longest
bushfire emergency ever and it's
creating anxiety among the general
public it's still a dry atmosphere we're
not getting any meaningful rain coming
through with this change so the winds
are still going to be breezy and they're
going to be dry in Australia's major
cities the political debate is heating
up these protesters are angry at how the
government has handled the crisis and
say the Prime Minister is reluctant to
connect the disaster with climate change
I'm here because I know we need to make
really big changes if we're going to
prevent these types of fires from
becoming regular everything the
government's doing is negative trying to
downplay the the causes and the reasons
for climate change
prime minister Scott Morrison says the
government will consider an inquiry into
the cause of the fires including the
role of climate change once the crisis
is over
Jessica Washington al-jazeera penrose
Australia